Speaker 1: We are going to hear from some
people in the audience.
We now take calls via Discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord.
Let's go first to an old friend.
I hope I still remember how to pronounce your
name.
This is a Lisa Madusa from Dallas that I do
OK.
Speaker 2: You did all right.
I appreciate the attempt, and it's great to
talk to you again, sir.
Yes.
Speaker 1: Thank you, sir.
What's going on?
Speaker 2: Yes, so I've noticed that on the
campaign trail for the midterms, many candidates,
including Josh Mandel, who I don't recommend
you looking up.
Yeah, they're promoting bitcoin and cryptocurrency,
and they're talking about how it's going to
be good for the future.
So I just like to get your thoughts on that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't have any emotional
attachment to or opposition to bitcoin or
cryptocurrency.
This is, you know, there's a lot of people
who are feeling the need to be extremely black
and white on crypto.
My view on crypto is as follows it's been
around over a decade at this point in time.
And while it is still very volatile, I see
no reason to think that it's going to go away
if scalability is addressed and transaction
fees are addressed.
I believe it's going to be around and I believe
it will.
There will be more adoption due to the level
of risk financially that crypto represents
the volatility.
My personal decision without advising anyone
else is I years ago put roughly three to five
percent of my assets in cryptocurrency.
That's done very well for me.
But I also recognize it could do poorly.
And that's why I only put in three to five
percent.
I am not super interested in the people who
either say crypto is the solution to everything
or crypto is the devil.
I don't think either is true, and I think
we've got to step away from these like overly
emotional assessments of it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree with you and I'm
in the same boat with crypto, I just have.
I'm not sure if it's like three percent right
now, but like I'm kind of like starting out
with investing.
So I'm probably going to hold off on buying
crypto for now and just like focus on just
ETFs.
But.
Yeah, thank you very much for taking my call,
and I hope that I'll have time next time to
call you again.
Speaker 1: I hope so.
All right.
Oh, from Dallas.
Always great to hear from him and kicking
ass off with some very, very strong topics.